- [Instructor] We are
told that for four days
you record the number of
hours you sleep each night.
You round each time to the
nearest 1/4 of an hour.
And then here on this table they tell us
that our different days,
they tell us how many hours we slept.
Day one we slept seven and 1/4 hours,
day two seven and 3/4,
day three seven and 3/4,
day four eight 1/2 hours.
Then it says, create a line plot
that shows all of the measurements
on the number line below.
And it says click above
the tick marks to add dots,
click on tick marks to remove dots.
So we can see if I click right over here,
a tick mark shows up.
And if I click again, it gets removed.
So let's see, day one you
slept seven and 1/4 hours.
So, that's one day where
you sleep seven and 1/4.
So, seven and 1/4 is right
between seven and seven and 1/2.
So that's right over there.
There we go.
On day two you sleep seven and 3/4 hours.
So, that's 1/4, 2/4, 3/4.
So that's day two.
Day three you also sleep
seven and 3/4 hours,
so that's another day that
you sleep seven and 3/4 hours.
And then on day four you
sleep eight and 1/2 hours,
which is right over there.
And so, here we go.
We have created a line plot
that shows all of the measurements.
On one day, day one it was,
I slept seven and 1/4 hours.
There were two days where I
slept seven and 3/4 hours,
and there was one day where
I slept eight and 1/2 hours.
Let's do another example.
Amy ran many miles during September.
She recorded how long it
took her to run each mile,
rounded to the nearest 1/4 of
a minute on the table below.
We can see it right over here,
actually let me move
my window a little bit
so you can see everything.
And then it says, create a line plot
that shows all of the measurements
on the number line below.
All right, so three times
she was able to run a mile
in eight and 3/4 minutes.
So, there are three
that were eight and 3/4.
Notice, this is, if we
look at the space between
eight and nine, there is one, two, three,
four equal intervals.
And so, 3/4 is going to be three of those.
One, two, three.
She ran a mile in eight and
3/4 minutes three times.
That's what we saw from that table.
So, that's three times she did that.
She ran a mile in nine
and 1/4 minutes two times.
So nine and 1/4.
That is 1/4 of the way to 10,
we can see 1/4, 2/4, 3/4, 4/4.
So nine and 1/4 she did two times.
So that's going to be one, two.
And then let's see, nine and 1/2
she did four times.
Nine and 1/2 is here, so
one, two, three, four.
And then eight and 1/2 she did one time.
So that's eight and 1/2 right over there.
And then she ran a mile in
nine minutes five times.
Nine minutes right over here.
One, two, three, four, five.
And we're done.